prise personne ne s'y attendait quel est
votre sentiment dans quel état d'esprit
êtes-vous on imagine que c'est
particulièrement difficile un oui une
très très grande tristesse parce que
j'aime beaucoup mon mandat donc
j'aimais beaucoup mon mandat donc une
très grande tristesse c'est vrai et puis
va coûter voilà c'est c'est le résultat
d'une division puisqu'il y avait cinq
listes les républicains voilà donc
normalement il n'y aurait dû avoir
peut-être un ou pas du tout de siège de
gauche et il ya eu trois sièges de
gauche à cause de cette division
voilà mépris de la division des
dissidences également absolument
absolument mais bon c'est comme ça c'est
la vie c'est la démocratie mais c'est
vrai que mes collègues qui n'avait pas
été élu à la députation ont souhaité
essayer de venir au sénat est pas ça m'a
coûté ma place mais bon voilà c'est la
vie encore une fois à à lui voix près
oui je crois 8 ou 11 ou après quelque
chose comme ça donc c'est très décevant
pour moi oui vraiment est ce que vous
allez demander à ce que les voix soient
recomptés je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
roger karoutchi est tête de liste
on verra ce qu'on fera je sais pas je ne
sais pas du tout ça va et ça vient
d'arriver on s'y attendait pas mais je
m'y attendais pas du tout c'est vrai et
je suis profondément triste parce que
bon c'est un mandat ou en plus vous
pouvez beaucoup aidé les gens vous
pouvez changer la vie des français c'est
un an +7 amanda que j'ai aimé
passionnément parce que vous n'avez pas
besoin justement d'être sous les feux
des projecteurs vous travaillez vraiment
en profondeur
c'est une assemblée extraordinaire où
vraiment cessé
c'est très riche le travail est très
riche les collègues sont très riches les
administrateurs sont très très fort
enfin vraiment un travail extrêmement
bien et d'ailleurs la preuve en est
c'est que 65% des amendements restent
dans la loi définitivement donc voilà
c'est une très grande tristesse pour moi
oui c'est vrai on sent que vous allez
avoir beaucoup de mal à quitter le sénat
oui j'aime passionnément cette maison et
mais bon encore une fois je vous dis
c'est la démocratie faut respecter le
choix des grands électeurs
isabelle debré de façon plus générale
comment analysez vous les résultats de
ce soir cette majorité de droite
conforte au sénat ce n'est pas vraiment
étonnant parce que on a les annonces du
président macron faisait que les palais
comme les communes sont inquiètes donc
et je crois qu'en plus ils voulaient un
contre-pouvoir mais un contre-pouvoir
intelligent c'est à dire que ici on a
toujours fait de l'opposition positive
jeudi plus constructive parce que on a
et c'était le souhait de gérard larcher
donc je pense que ça continuera on n'est
pas une chambre ou ou ont réagi dans
l'immédiat pts et si vous voulez donc
c'est vraiment que quelque chose de
réfléchi et on prend vraiment des
décisions qui sont bonnes pour le pays
voilà donc aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est bien d'avoir un contre-pouvoir
mais encore une fois c'est pas négatif
un contre-pouvoir positif où chacun va
pouvoir travailler
et puis je crois que c'est bien aussi
d'avoir des gens un peu expérimentée
parce que l'assemblée nationale est un
peu impulsive et en plus il ya beaucoup
de nouveaux donc c'est bien qu'ils aient
se balance cette balance et je pense que
ce sera très très bien pour le pays